mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalker
start with an equilateral triangle
construct a row of four congruent
equilateral triangles
connect the leftmost vertex of the first
triangle to the top vertex of the fourth
triangle
then consider the region above this line
contained within the first three
triangles
if a single equilateral triangle has an
area equal to six
what is the area of the region shaded in
yellow
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
to begin
connect a line segment between the top
four vertices of these equilateral
triangles
because the equilateral triangles are
congruent corresponding sides will be
parallel to each other
therefore the large triangle in yellow
will be similar to the middle triangle
in yellow and it will be similar to the
smallest triangle in yellow
suppose each equilateral triangle has a
side length equal to s
then this is equal to s this is equal to
s and this side is also equal to s
thus the side lengths will be in parts
of three
the middle triangle will have a side
length that's equal to two-thirds
multiplied by s and the smallest
triangle will have a side length that's
equal to one-third multiplied by s
now construct one more equilateral
triangle
this side length will also be equal to s
the line segments going the other way
will be in parts of four
so the largest triangle in yellow will
have a side length this way that's equal
to three over four multiplied by s the
middle triangle will be equal to two
over four multiplied by s and the
smallest will be one over four
multiplied by s
from here
we will calculate the area of the
largest triangle shown in yellow
now because each triangle is an
equilateral triangle this will be 60
degrees
so its area will be one half multiplied
by s multiplied by three over 4
multiplied by s multiplied by the sine
of the angle between it which is 60
degrees
now sine of 60 degrees is equal to the
square root of 3 over 2.
thus this simplifies to be the following
we also have the area of a single
equilateral triangle is equal to six
and that's equal to s squared over four
multiplied by the square root of three
thus we can substitute in six for that
part and we get the area of the large
yellow triangle is equal to 3 over 4
multiplied by 6 which is equal to 4.5
from here
the similarity factor between the
largest and the next largest triangle is
2 over three
so their areas will be in the square of
that so we have four point five
multiplied by two over three squared
the smallest triangle has a similarity
ratio of one over three so its area will
be the square of 1 over 3 multiplied by
4.5
we can thus calculate the area of each
triangle
once we do that we add up these areas
and we get the answer is equal to seven
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube
see you next episode of mind your
decisions where we solve the world's
problems one video at a time
[Music]
you